personally i really want to see how  apple pulled off you know having so much  performance in such a small package now  vadim and i spent a ton of time  yesterday trying to figure out the best  way to open this up so the first thing  we're going to do is take off this  rubber ring so i thought the whole shell  would just come off so it looks like the  next step is to unconnect this whole top  portion which is the power supply this  is built very well i thought a lot of  this would be plastic but no it's all  aluminum obviously the ram is not  upgraded what's on the soc that looks  like you can put an ssd into it you  literally have to disassemble everything  to get this out one eternity later  the front is most of the weight and the  chip is  massive dang i would not recommend doing  this  there you go dual sided cooling and look  at that beauty right there this m1 ultra  is literally i don't know half of the  whole motherboard size